joe moeller and the i-team's vanessa
murphy live tonight with reaction from
the cycling community
as well as safety tips for cyclists but
first
let's begin with kristin drummond who is
live at the scene with more on what
exactly
happened kristen
denise and brian the deadly crash
happening across the highway from me
here on u.s 95
south at around 9 30 this morning the
location is about
15 miles north of searchlight the
southbound lanes were shut down for
about six hours today troopers say about
10 cyclists were riding south when a
white box truck driving the same
direction
went into their lane now the reason why
remains unknown right now but
impairment is not suspected nhp confirms
four men and one woman died three others
were hurt including one who was
airlifted to
umc trauma nhp says the cyclists on the
ride were familiar with the route and
made this trip before
a support and gear car also known as a
sag vehicle
also accompanied them until today's
tragedy
they've never had any problems they
didn't have it so you can be with
them what i understand though is the
safety vehicle
ended up in a position where there were
bicyclists both in front of it
at the time of this crash
the driver of the sag car was
hospitalized
and hp says the box truck driver was not
hurt
and cooperated with troopers i'm told
that the cyclists who participated in
the group ride are all
advanced cyclists and this is all part
of a 130 mile
bike birthday ride now this has
definitely been shocking
many in the cyclist community joe
moeller is north of me on u.s
95 after speaking with cyclists today
and
joe what's their reaction to all of this
yeah well other riders who were in this
group along the 95 and other people in
the bicycling community are wondering
how exactly this crash happened